[Musique]
l'élection présidentielle maintenant
c'est dans sept mois mais il ya déjà des
sondages vous le savez alors que
distille alors le président de la
république sortant qui n'est pas encore
candidat à cette élection eh bien il est
en tête des intentions de vote pour le
premier tour avec 23% des voix devant
marine le pen vous voyez 19% xavier
bertrand à droite 14 % jean-luc
mélenchon 11% et 10% pour eric zemmour
dont on ne sait pas encore non plus s'il
sera candidat ou pas et animer le débat
d'entre deux tours participer à votre
manière l'éléphant d'asie dans ciel si
vous voulez que ce soit elle tapait un
nom
je
dirais que je suis co cette résidence
alors
c'est pas terminé non
c'est pas une présidence à vie le bilan
global de ces jeux olympiques n'est pas
tout à fait au niveau que nous
attendions on sait que sur certains
sports il est même mitigé et on peut pas
construire une réussite si on ne se dit
pas les choses en vérité la france est
une grande menace est une grande nation
du sport maintenant se dire qu'on va
faire 90 médaille à paris 2004 non
j'aimerais me j'aimerais qu'on me fasse
mentir mais il faut faire beaucoup plus
de choses pour pouvoir prétendre à 90
médailles en trois ans
bairi le i ce que fait le dragon quand
il est en forme
[Musique]
[Rires]
la plus vieille haltérophiles du monde
elle est américaine elle s'appelle édité
à la cent ans mais oui ça c'est
magnifique nerfs qui soulève de la fonte
elle participe à des compètes elle
soulève 28 kg au développé couché elle
explique qu'elle compte bien continuer à
s'entraîner dur pour les prochaines
compet faut dire qu'elle a commencé sur
le tard edit s'est mise à
l'haltérophilie à l'âge de 91 ans
merci grand nancy
merci francis
une longévité qui est dû aussi sans
doute à vos rituels avant de prendre
l'antenne un caleçon rouge des bâtons
d'ensemble de la musique des antennes du
19e siècle dans la loge est toujours
commencer par le pied droit quand on
tirait un plateau pour une première fois
exactement le pied gauche portman enfin
c'est des trucs tu peux plus dire
aujourd'hui pourquoi le pied gauche et
j'ai une question patrice c'est qu'il a
ses valeurs aviatrice est décédé ouais
d'accord
ok ok ok ok ok merci pas vrai ça
bon ça jette un froid là
je suis prêt pour la vidéo après cette
séquence jordan cheyenne une maman
youtube d'américaines l'aide diffusé par
erreur à ces cinq cent mille abonnés
les chauffeurs des jarries pendant une
minute la trentenaire demande à son fils
de 9 ans de pleurer devant l'objectif
alors qu'ils viennent d'apprendre que
leur chien malade et pour obtenir la
photo qui illustrera la vidéo elle
n'hésite pas lui montrer comment faire
non non non mais là mon candidat comme
dirait johnny noir c'est noir il ya plus
d'espoir
on est des gens heureux nous les
chasseurs j'ai toujours dit on à 1 en 1
min n de communication là dessus mais
c'est vrai voilà je vois des voix la
tête des dégâts face deux mois sur les
des plateaux de télé géante qu'est ce
que les mecs se font chier dans leur vie
comme leur président une tête de cocker
dépression nous on est des mecs heureux
on aime la vie on aime la nature on aime
tout ça et on s'y sent bien qu'ils aient
accès dedans selon vous des asticots
voilà des verts il est fabriqué en
italie en sardaigne exactement il a été
élu par le guinness des records comme le
fromage le plus dangereux du monde il a
été interdit en vente en europe depuis
2005 il paraîtrait qui s'échange à plus
de 1000 euros le cargo au marché noir
mais personnellement je mettrai pas
d'une façon marc tougas pouvait refuser
en italien c'est à dire un husky gratte
on comprend bien
on arrive en patrice m'a vanté tous les
produits frais à cartes et maintenant je
suis un petit peu moins ça aurait quand
même là c'est congélateur c'est un
congélateur oui c'est possible c'est pas
pour jouer
bon il est vrai chez 1
eh ben on peut tous jetés parce que
c'était brésil on a des problèmes
électriques les prises et marche pas à
la cuisine c'est vraiment là le rideau
quoi
loulou quelques sections t'abuse
tu mets le doigt là où ça fait mal et je
suis arrivé à saturation
c'est curieux côté pas de bestioles
là-dedans souhaitais retrouver des
bestioles tu crois ah oui mais lui même
du mobile
y avait du vomi parce que c'est un peu
coagulé la sauce et coller des petits
bouts truc je m'attendais à tellement de
belles choses avec son intitulé viande
rouge pour nuits blanches sibérienne que
là on avait l'impression que la viande
avait été relâchée prédigéré c'est quoi
ça prend ça [ __ ] ça ça pur donc ça
fait un moment que c'est comme ça c'est
ni fait ni à faire
vous 15 ans d'expérience mais je sais
pas ce que vous avez fait reste que en
15 ans
j'ai mangé là dedans six étaient venus
avant en cuisine et j'aurais pas bouffer
je serais même pas essayé de me manger
quoi que ce soit alors alors alors je
vais parler d'oeuvres d'art comme un ver
côté nasa c'est une étude que je fais
sur les projections de pollock tu
connais pas là vraiment artistes
déjantés aucun cas utiliser d'autres
tachisme et étoiles par terre
ces deux appareils bloqués arrêtez de
nous casser les couilles élue miss
france en 1987 7 qui a été sa chaperonne
trouve depuis des années que nathalie ne
leur pas l'écharpé de miss en raison de
son comportement trop vulgaire à son
goût ce qu'elle n'a pas manqué de
rappeler lors d'une interview dans
l'instant de luxe j'ai jamais compris ce
qui lui est passé par la tête quand elle
a commencé à parler d'eux et tout ça
deux trucs de guerre ça vous alors il y
en a une qui a refusé de se faire
vacciner pour venir au maître c'est la
rappeuse nicki minaj une décision
qu'elle a justifié par des doutes sur la
fiabilité du vote
ça peut faire sourire mais c'est
carrément devenu un roubignolles gates
quand le docteur fochi a dû rassurer
tous les propriétaires de testicules
chez trois
sets
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
jean pierre mas pas parce qu'elle elle
dit aussi que jean pierre mas et posée
par rapport à mon écharpe je pense que
c'est pas pour mon écharpe mais plutôt
pour mon cul qui menait
3 2 1
[Musique]